[Musique]
enfin
l'avion est intacte ya clooney qui est
coupée tu peux passer la tête par le
cockpit d'avion est rempli de poissons
[Musique]
dans le fiji kawama ou qu'elles ont un
numéro un
trois petits avions de combat japonais
là j'ai pris deux manches de l'avion et
j'ai regarder droit devant mais j'étais
comme si c'était la deuxième guerre
mondiale comme si j'étais en 1944 j'ai
essayé de voler et de pas me faire tuer
c'est vraiment une chose incroyable
affaire trente mètres sous l'eau c'est
magique et mystérieux
c'est l'un des plus grands cimetières
marins du monde 51 navires japonais et
400 avions ont coulé au fond de ce lagon
en 1944 pourquoi cet épisode méconnu de
la deuxième guerre mondiale s'est il
déroulé ici au coeur de cet archipel
perdu de micronésie à chuck
on se le demande encore
leur jeu
[Musique]
le malheur des habitants de tchouk est
née d'un hasard géographique leur lagon
profond est idéalement situé pour
abriter l'une des plus importantes bases
navales et aériennes japonaises
c'est le bastion à abattre à tout prix
pour les américains qui en février 1944
vont déversé un déluge de bombes sur
l'archipel
[Musique]
c'est leur revanche de pearl harbour
quatre mille soldats japonais vont y
perdre la vie
[Musique]
le cauchemar d'hier s'est métamorphosé
en trevor un trésor qui fascine les
plongeurs du monde entier mais un trésor
qui se disloque corrosion pêche à la
dynamite
des scientifiques australiens rêve de
sauver ces épaves devenu l'unique
ressource touristique de tchouk mais
ont-ils la moindre chance d'y arriver
[Musique]
les touristes qui débarquent à chuke
sont tous des fondus de plonger comme
cette famille qui arrive de floride
et
on est très excité c'est le voyage de
notre vie c'était notre rêve de venir
ici
m
il parcourt l'unique route de lille et
son envie d'écouter non c'est parce
qu'ils peuvent apercevoir cette
incroyable et un aîné tout à plus de 20
ans des baraques de tôle sans fenêtre je
serais surpris si l'on le courant entre
pas d'air conditionné que les choses
sont vraiment différente aux états unis
il se raccroche à des repères familiers
il ya des sens oui oui il ya des sens
c'est joli quand même
kuroda neumatt g conditions c'est autre
chose est certaine j'ai appris
l'histoire de notre île par ma mère mon
père et ma grand mère
[Musique]
elle était née avant que le japonais de
20 d'ici vie des gens très simples
faciles parce qu'ils vivaient de leur
récolte de leur pêche pas là dessus
ils travaillaient tous ensemble de
s'entraider partager ce qu'ils avaient
pour vivre
[Musique]
première plongée pour la famille boyle
ils ont choisi l'épave la plus célèbre
de la gombe celle du fujikawa ma roue
[Musique]
oh
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
canon le canon sur le pont tu l'as vue
incroyable il fait 10 mètres de long
c'est gigantesque c'est d'en rire dès
que des sens c'est vraiment super les
épaves j'en ai vu mais c'était rien à
côté de celle ci c'est un voyage dans le
temps vraiment
[Musique]
pour m
ilo idyllique épaves majestueuse récifs
coralliens choc a tout pour séduire les
visiteurs mais ceux ci demeurent bien
peu nombreux à peine 3000 par an
cette extraordinaire cimetière marin a
beau être classé monument national
que peut-il réellement changé au
quotidien difficile des tchouktches
longtemps administrée par les américains
qui n'ont jamais réellement investi dans
cet archipel trucks obtient son
indépendance en 1986 et reprend son os
traditionnel celui de tchouk aujourd'hui
l'archipel reste englué dans la pauvreté
le chômage la corruption sans réelles
ressources naturelles sans la moindre
industrie le principal employeur reste
l'état devenir fonctionnaire le seul
avenir les jeunes rêvent d'émigrer aux
états unis la plupart des gens s'en
sortent grâce à une économie de
subsistance
[Musique]
l'un des plus gros problèmes sur l'île
principal c'est celui du logement
ils sont une trentaine de membres de la
même famille à habiter chez leur oncle
mari celui-ci héberge ceux qui n'ont pas
d'autre choix
leur île et à 400 km ici c'est le seul
endroit un peu développés où ils peuvent
étudier où trouver du travail
les épaves
j'y pense pas ça m'intéresse pas ça ne
me concerne pas tout ce que ça me
rappelle c'est la guerre je sais pas je
ne comprends pas pourquoi il ya eu la
guerre ils sont j'ai lu l'histoire
je pense que c'est parce que les
japonais sont venus en premier ils ont
bien compris que cet endroit pouvait
leur être très profitable mais pour eux
pas pour les gens d'ici
d'après ce que mes parents m'ont dit les
japonais au début quand ils sont arrivés
nous était bon mais quelques années plus
tard ils ont décidé que tout ici leur
appartenait
au japonais sont venus sur l'île après
la première guerre non seulement le
chapeau à supplanter l'allemagne
il voulait que les habitants coach ou
apprennent à écrire le japonais a parlé
le japonais bridgestone cup
ils voulaient du pied les gens disent
ils qu'ils apprennent la façon de vivre
des japonais
quand le japon s'est entraîné tout a
changé sur l'île à berne
il regroupait tous les hommes de fuch
ils les ont utilisés comme main d'oeuvre
ils ont construit les pistes
d'atterrissage la base hydravion ils ont
ici les canaux des montagnes les
militaires pouvaient obtenir tout ce
qu'il voulait à damas
par exemple même si jamais ils pouvaient
mener et la garder dans leur maison
bonjour mes sentiments pour les japonais
j'étais terrifiée parce qu'il nous
forcer à travailler comme des esclaves
on n'a jamais essayé de résister aux
japonais les combattre on avait bien
trop peur de cette époque là je savais
plongée j'aimerais bien voir de mes yeux
ce qu'il y à l'intérieur des épaves pour
voir les épaves il faut apprendre à
plonger
il faut du matériel il faut de l'argent
pour nous c'est très difficile parce que
nous sommes très pauvres
on ne peut pas prendre des cours de
plongée il n'y a que les gens riches qui
peuvent faire ça sur l'île l'économie va
mal
la pêche depuis peu ne s'exporte plus le
tourisme même modeste est désormais la
seule activité économique consistante de
lille est une des rares sources
d'emplois face à un chômage qui loin des
chiffres officiels frôlerait les 70%
grade ville a hérité du centre de
plongée de son père
le premier de l'île et dans cette
société basée sur la famille la
solidarité joue à fond d'oeil
aujourd'hui nous employons beaucoup de
monde la plupart sont de la famille des
cousins des neveux des ongles nous
travaillons tous ensemble pour le centre
de plongée
mon premier boulot à la boutique de
plongée c'était de ramasser du couple et
puis d instructeur de plongée américains
sont venus et ils nous ont donné des
cours et je suis devenu guide de plongée
c'était mon rêve
elle a pris du temps mais je devais
réaliser son travail jusqu'à l'âge de 40
ans nikto maintenant faire vivre sa
famille décemment en passant sa vie sur
les épaves
ils ont 300 jours par an et de plongée
par jour ça fait six ans par an c'est ma
quinzième année en tant que guide
[Applaudissements]
alors voilà
le côté que nous allons découvrir
s'appelle le sens qu'ils sont un autre
bateau de transport quand il était
encore la surface il a été bombardé par
vos avions et c'est ce qu'il a fait
couler dans laquelle numéro 3 on peut
voir des flacons de médicaments et des
bouteille de saké dans laquelle numéro 2
on peut voir des camions des châssis des
moteurs d'avions des trains
d'atterrissage
[Musique]
dans lequel numéros y trouvera des
milliers de bals et des détonateurs
[Musique]
vous a plu
si vous êtes heureux je suis heureux
c'est ça mon boulot rendre les gens
heureux
c'est pour ça que ce qu'il remonte sur
le pont et me remercient
je suis très heureux hattab rend fier
fier de mon travail
voilà ma petite maison comme je suis un
homme pauvre ma maison n'est pas
vraiment somptueuse c'est comme ça que
je n'avais pas de travail je voulais pas
ma vie j'aurais pas pu entretenir une
famille
nick pense que son travail est menacé
depuis quinze ans il a vu les étapes se
détériorer peu à peu certaines parties
des bateaux se sont déjà écoulés comme
les mains quand les épreuves se sont
effondrés j'aurais plus rien à faire
lorsque les plongeurs ne viendront plus
je travaille pas à l'argent ne manie pas
d'argent mais de survie
[Musique]
ces menaces qui pèsent sur les épaves
bill jeffery les connaît bien
cela fait six ans que cet archéologue
australien vient régulièrement un choc
pour travailler il y a urgence ici les
épaves ont souffert de toute une série
d' interférence naturelles et humaines
certaines parties des navires se sont
effondrés d'autres ont été endommagées
par la pêche à la dynamite quelques
épaves n'ont plus que 10 à 15 en voit
beaucoup moins inventifs
j'espère qu'on peut faire changer les
choses et pour ça on a une association
intéressante de scientifiques qui
travaillaient ensemble
et
bill jeffrey a su tisser de solides
liens d'amitié avec les gens de tchouk
notamment avec gravelines dont il
utilise le centre de plongée
bill est fier de lui présenter son
équipe
biologiste spécialiste de la corrosion
conservateur de musée
c'est un mélange peu commun de
compétences pour affronter au mieux tous
les problèmes qui touchent les épaves
j'ai fait pas mal de changements sur les
épaves durant la dernière plongée de
dégâts oui plus de dégâts une partie de
notre travail ça va être d'étudier ces
dégâts ses causes et comment on peut les
ralentir ouais ça serait bien d'avoir
votre expertise pour nous conseiller sur
ce qu'il faut faire
[Musique]
l'équipe doit d'abord étudier l'état
actuel de ce patrimoine sous-marin avec
plus de 50 épaves a répertorié la tâche
est gigantesque
il faut du monde et de l'argent bill a
fait appel à un mode de financement à
ces nouveaux et très en vogue dans le
monde de l'environnement l'éco
volontariat
la mission est financé par des bénévoles
qui paient pour participer à cette
expédition
seule condition c'est éco volontaires
doivent avoir une excellente maîtrise de
la plongée
chaque jour il leur faut une demi-heure
de bateau avant de s'arrêter au-dessus
des épaves
[Musique]
les biologistes mike enzi et jose qu'ils
plongent souvent parmi les premiers
[Musique]
j'observe les coraux en particulier ceux
qui ont été endommagés par des encres
les plongeurs ou de la dynamite
car chaque coup porté au concrétions de
l'épave va accélérer sa corrosion
mike s'occupe lui d'identifier et de
dénombrer les poissons que les et par
attire systématiquement
il n'y avait pas d'épave au fond de
l'eau à venir est qu'un nombre limité
d'espèces qui livrait là celle qui
creuse des trous dans le sable est celle
qui picorent les rares cailloux
l'épave s'échouer mais plein de petits
poissons débarque c'est un endroit super
pour vivre il ya plein d'endroits pour
se cacher et se protéger des prédateurs
ensuite vous allez les prédateurs
bienvenue pour se nourrir de ces petits
poissons et enfin les herbivores des
ménages pour se nourrir les algues qui
poussent sur les épaves
donc c'est tout d'un petit microcosme
qui secret tu vas mesurée à partir de
ces différents points alors une fois que
je descends là je dois les verrous toi
que tu restes au point et je ferai les
mesures les autres les écovolontaires
apprennent vite à travailler à 20 mètres
de profondeur pour certains la tâche est
assez facile il s'agit de tenir le
décamètre et de se positionner au bon
endroit pour permettre une cartographie
juste de l'épave
mais pour d'autres le travail s'avère
beaucoup plus compliqué ils doivent
utiliser sous l'eau le système des
cadres à c'est-à-dire cadre et un
endroit en identifier le contenu le
mesurer le photographier puis le
dessiner nommée joyce sont des jeunes
retraités américains
c'est la première fois de leur vie
qu'ils doivent effectuer un tel travail
sous l'eau
c'était difficile de maintenir son
équilibre de garder chaque chose en
place pendant qu'on mesure est elle se
souvenir de tout ce qu'il y avait à
faire et communiqué à temps revient on
n'a pas mesuré sa sans pouvoir se parler
ils vont sûrement balancer nos premières
mesures
[Musique]
ils détiennent l'ancien quartier général
de l'aviation japonaise pendant la
guerre l'équipe australienne découvre ce
qui fut l'un des premiers objectifs à
abattre pour les américains en 1944
c'est encore un bâtiment fantôme
peut-être moins excitant à découvrir
mais beaucoup plus troublant
comme si la brutalité de la guerre était
plus perceptible à terre
[Musique]
cho'gath est l'une des bases les plus
importantes à neutraliser pour les
amériques
il l'a considéré comme le gibraltar du
passif y était l'équivalent de l'arbre
et quand ils sont venus pour la bonne
garde et il en outre alizés mais ils ne
l'ont pas envahi ils ont préféré la
laisser pourrir sur pied comme ils
disent et ils ont fait savoir à l'époque
que c'était leur revanche de pearl
harbor c'était aussi important que ça
pour les américains le 17 février 1944
l'opération secrète elle storne tempête
de grêle commence
c'est une attaque aérienne contre le
bastion japonais les américains
redoutent le pire mystérieuse la base
est réputée imprenable
[Musique]
les bombardiers américains commencent
par pilonner la défense aérienne
japonaise
[Musique]
ce qui m'a fait le secteur quand ils ont
lâché leurs bombes
vous allez bruit des explosions et la
façon dont les bombes ont secoué le sol
ça m'a vraiment aidé
c'était la première fois que je voyais
des choses comme ça mon village il a été
balayé par les américains ils sont
bombardés depuis le haut des montagnes
jusqu'au mans grande
beaucoup de gens de mon village sont
morts je les ai vus mourir devant moi
j'ai vu leurs intestins à sortir de leur
ventre champions j'en ai vu perdre leur
prénom de google
dans le lagon la plupart des navires de
guerre ont déjà fui alertés par un vol
de reconnaissance américain de semaine
plus tôt mais beaucoup de navires
marchands sont encore là pour décharger
le ravitaillement de l'armement des
tanks des camions de la nourriture des
médicaments
les navires ne résiste pas à deux jours
de bombardements intenses les pertes
humaines sont très lourdes
quatre mille soldats japonais meurent
l'archipel de chuck est défigurée
kendrick niveau ce road show bike shop
point de presse donné vis au maroc ali
[Musique]
ils ont balancé tellement de bombes
vous pouvez vous en rendre compte avec
le nombre d'épaves dans le lagon qu'est
ce que ça a donné
les gens d'ici ont souffert soldats
japonais sont morts je ne vois aucune
raison à tout ça peut-être c'est parce
qu'on n'avait pas de machines comme une
mitrailleuse des bombes et d'autres
choses comme ça mais pourquoi ils sont
venus jusqu'ici pour se battre je ne
sais pas pourquoi les japonais sont
arrivés ici pour commencer je ne sais
pas non plus je complète sera peut-être
qu'il essayait de nous apporter la
civilisation la civilisation occidentale
nous on était bien avant qu'il n'arrive
et un autre face on avait pas de rythme
et on vivait on était heureux
[Musique]
depuis 1944 ces épaves dorment dans le
lagon de tchouk
il reste à leur bord au moins trente six
mille tonnes de pétrole
comment prévenir toute pollution
catastrophique
comment éviter tout effondrement mortel
sur des plongeurs pour le savoir
l'équipe scientifique australienne doit
déterminer très précisément l'état de
corrosion de chaque épave
[Musique]
vous ne pouvez pas savoir si le métal
est en bonne santé ou pas simplement le
regardant parce qu'il est recouvert par
une couche de coraux et d'agde
il faut donc percée à travers tout cela
afin de placer nos électrodes tous
contre le métal ian mcleod est l'un des
meilleurs spécialistes au monde de la
corrosion des métaux il ausculte ces
épaves comme un médecin prendre à
l'attention d'un patient l'action
corrosive créer un courant électrique
qu'il parvient à mesurer il m'a fallu
douze ans avant que je puisse confondre
tous que cette tension électrique sur
toutes les différentes étapes pouvait
signifier
et puis un jour soudainement ça s'est
mis en place
les ehpad me parle quand je prends les
mesures elles me font savoir s'ils vont
bien
les gens me disent mais comment une et
par peut-elle parler seulement il faut
savoir ouvre les yeux et les oreilles
mettre tous ses sens en éveil et
observaient toujours observées sur les
tâches que vous expliquer ce qui se
parent des lignes
les shows qu'ils ont failli ne jamais
réalisé qu'un véritable trésor reposait
dans leur lagon
après la guerre s'il leur arrive de
plongée en apnée sur des épaves c'est
uniquement pour récupérer du métal ce
n'est qu'à la fin des années 60 que tout
va changer
après la visite d'un célèbre bonhomme au
bonnet rouge cousteau a été le premier à
filmer les épaves de tchouk le short
roll choisi ce malaise
u15 pousser encore un peu regarde encore
de nourriture
et voilà ça a disparu
[Musique]
selon les australiens la visite de
l'équipe costaud n'a pas laissé que des
bons souvenirs savant de différentes
sources que cousteau a ramené on ne voit
que quelques articles dans le film c'est
intéressant je m'attendais à voir des
cloches des télégraphes de pont d'autres
plus imposante
nous ne savons pas où on va essayer de
pister mais il est probable qu'on ne
retrouve jamais et ce serait vraiment
formidable si ça pouvait revenir à des
shows pour un musée le film de cousteau
va jouer un rôle décisif dans l'histoire
de tchouk ces images vont fasciné les
plongeurs du monde entier qui débarque
dans l'archipel dans les années 70 la
seule personne qui sur place peut les
aider c'est qu'ils me au s1 qu il a
appris à plonger à hawaï
il travaille pour le département des
ressources maritimes et se débrouille
toujours pour remplir les bouteilles de
plongée des visiteurs il rend service
sans imaginer que cela va bouleverser sa
vie c'est lié d'amitié avec ses
visiteurs américains et ils l'ont poussé
à ouvrir une boutique de plonger un ben
euh euh tu m'avais très vite compris que
tout allait devenir un endroit culte
pour la plongée sur des épaves
non papa
ils ne comprenaient même pas ce que
c'était une boutique est plongé je me
disais tu sais a plongé sur du métal
je ne trouve pas ça très intéressant moi
je préfère plonger sur des récifs
c'est bien mieux parce que là je peux
ramasser des classes des choix repos
j'ai toujours quelque chose à rapporter
à la maison ils voyaient pas l'intérêt
pourquoi est ce que des gens vivraient
projet sur les trucs en métal kim hyo va
vite réaliser combien les étrangers
aiment d'aller voir ces fameux truc en
métal
de kennedy junior à james cameron son
centre de plongée rencontre le succès
charismatique le pionnier se bat dès le
début pour préserver les épaves en tant
que musée freine les vols empêche les
pillages et impose le respect de ce
sanctuaire
car qui mieux avec plus les
bombardements il avait 17 ans il a vu
les bateaux japonais couler
sur l'un d'eux se trouvait son ami un
japonais alors qu'il travaillait sur les
docks
mon père et lui étaient très proches
fois qu'il plongeait sur son bateau il
apporte des fleurs pour saluer la
mémoire de son ami il resta sur le
bateau ils ne parlaient pas pendant un
moment
parce qu'il avait vu se battre coups
légers point bas
[Musique]
à
à chaque fois que je planche sur une
épave
j'imagine la façon dont les gens sont
morts je me demande et si ça avait été
moi qu'est ce que j'avais fait qu'est ce
que ces milliers de personnes ont pu
faire coincé à l'intérieur du bateau
avec l'eau qui montait
[Musique]
samar période en tout cas s'il ya des
vieux qui disent c'est bien fait s'ils
sont morts comme ça je pense qu'il ne
pardonne pas ce qu'on leur fait un jour
des japonais qui avaient vécu sur l'île
ce revenu et des jus de chou qui sont
arrivés avec leurs machettes ils
voulaient se battre avec eux nous avons
beaucoup de touristes japonais qui
wenger je vous dirais que 5 % d'entre
eux ont envie de touche sur les 95 %
préfèrent aller plonger sur les récifs
en dehors du lago peut-être ressenti
quelque chose quand il pour sur leur
propre bateau
les touristes étrangers quand ils voient
des os ça leur plaît ils sont comme
émoustillés à la vue des crânes des
tidianes mais quand les japonais eux se
retrouvent dans les zones où il ya des
ossements ils sont choqués et ils
ressentent beaucoup de tristesse
c'est normal ce sont nos ancêtres c'est
notre peuple ce sont nos familles qui
sont mortes pendant cette guerre
quel que soit le temps l'équipe
australienne multiplie les plongées
apprend à déchiffrer ce fameux langage
des épaves cher à ian mcleod
celles ci ne vont pas disparaître demain
matin mais se disloquer un peu plus
chaque jour suivant l'inexorable destin
de tout objet métallique d'anglo de mer
enfin ce qu'on a toujours considéré
jusqu'à présent comme inexorable
car ian mcleod va tout simplement
changer le destin de ces épaves
on sait d'après nos calculs que le
fujikawa marc ou encore duré entre 5 et
12 ans va rester dans l'état
watkins est ce qu'on peut faire c'est
traiter les paroles à conserver sur
flash traiter la corrosion du métal mais
fabriquons une couche de carbonate de
calcium et ce serait comme l'enveloppé
dans une merveilleuse converties sur 5
elle nous dira voilà je n'aurai plus
m'effondrer
[Musique]
à
ans
il y a les rêves fous de mcleod qui
imaginent sans cesse des plans de
sauvetage et puis il ya la réalité des
missions limitées dans le temps qu'ils
espèrent multiplié pendant trois ans
s'il trouve assez des coups volontaires
pour les financer
[Musique]
quant au budget que l'état de choc peut
consacrer la préservation des épaves
il apparaît totalement dérisoire aux
yeux de bill jeffery en australie on a
une seule par deux le même taille le
yang a là on a du mal à s'en sortir
ici c'est un pays très pauvre il doit
cette était de 50 épaves gigantesque on
peut pas s'attendre arrive à gérer cela
quand nous un pays bien doté on a du mal
avec une seule épreuve
ces bateaux et des japonais ils ont été
coulés par les américains ont cédé leurs
gains justice de s'en occuper alors que
c'est un pays de misère les américains
les japonais devrait donner davantage
d'argent hotchkiss pour prendre soin ne
sais pas
aux etats unis les épaves de guerre
contenant des restes humains sont
interdites aux plongeurs mais à chuke
les touristes peuvent toucher les
ossements choqué révolté
l'association des familles des soldats
japonais a réagi mon père et deux
cousins on a aidé les japonais récupérer
les restes humains sur les épaves
[Musique]
je me souviens que c'était très
troublant d'aller creuser là dedans il
m'a fallu une semaine pour que je
m'habitue à ramasser ce mot et puis
aller déposer de plus en plus vite dans
des salles au début je n'étais pas
rassuré j'étais nerveux parce que j'ai
peur des fantômes
le but de ces cérémonies est de libérer
les âmes des défunts
les familles ont donc tout fait pour que
les ossements soit incinérée et les
cendres rapatriés au japon
car selon la religion japonaise shinto
l'âme des morts ne peut trouver la paix
tant qu'ils ne sont pas enterrés dans
leur propre pays
[Musique]
on
sur chacune des épaves l'équipe
australienne traque tous les indices qui
leur permettront de résoudre la question
la plus importante
combien de temps combien de temps ces
monstres d'acier résisteront-ils
il est trop tôt pour se prononcer
précisément les épaves tiendrait encore
le coût 5 à 15 ans mais ian mcleod
préfère déjà se concentrer sur une autre
question que faire concrètement pour que
ces épaves résiste à l'épreuve du temps
comment faire pour empêcher qu'elle ne
disparaisse
[Musique]
des capteurs reliés à lait par an n'est
pas rage le courant électrique circulera
dans le métal qui arrêtera la corrosion
et on pourra vraiment préserver ses
parts pour toujours une des choses
formidables avec l'électrochimie
convention c'est que tout ça c'est une
histoire d'électrons qui tombe ma vie
donc en fait cet engouement que l'on
peut renverser notre boulot c'est
d'essayer de faire durer l'histoire les
hauts-lieux d'extirper tous là pour le
mettre dans un musée on créera amusé
sous l'eau dans le lagon et on
sécurisera les épaves pour que les
prochaines générations puissent en
profiter
[Musique]
stoppez la corrosion des épaves dans la
mer c'est une véritable révolution
l'opération n'a jamais été réalisée sur
une épave entière mais ian mcleod a déjà
expérimenté avec succès cette technique
sur des encres et des canons
la prouesse scientifique ne lui fait pas
peur le coût financier pourrait être
envisagée mais pour que cette solution
extraordinaire puisse être réaliste
l'équipe doit affronter un autre
problème qui frappe au coeur même des
épaves celui de la pêche à la dynamite
aujourd'hui ils ont l'impression d'avoir
marqué un point contre ce fléau
alors je n'avais jamais trouvé une
acidité du métal aussi importante
qu'aujourd'hui cela correspond
parfaitement aux dégâts provoqués par
les ondes de choc de la dynamite
utilisés par les pêcheurs
si vous voulez les pabx elle fait comme
ça je suis très malheureux pour la
première fois nous sommes arrivés
presque immédiatement après les dégâts
donc on peut les mesurer jusqu'à
maintenant c'était l'habitude est ce la
faute d'un typhon est de la dynamite
on sait qu'il ya pas les petits font
donc la pêche à la dynamite
[Musique]
en prouvant que les épaves sont
directement menacés l'équipe
australienne arrivera peut être à
remobiliser la lutte contre ce problème
de société
la technique de la pêche à la dynamite a
été enseignée par les japonais aux
locaux lorsqu ils m'auraient tous de
faim après les bombardements
depuis les choses qu'ils n'ont jamais
été à court de munitions puisqu'elle
abondent à terre et sur les épaves ou
les pêcheurs viennent se servir
les piles bien rangée de mines diminue
sans cesse on voit très bien ce qui
manque
[Musique]
bill jeffery sait combien cette pêche à
la dynamite peut ruiner non seulement
les épaves
mais l'avenir de tchouk l'archéologue
n'hésite pas à jouer les sociologues en
quête de solutions
il a convaincu des pêcheurs à la
dynamite de lui parler
ces derniers ont souhaité rester anonyme
je ne veux pas que vous vous sentiez mal
à l'aise je ne cherche pas ce que vous
sentiez coupable g2 simplement
comprendre le procédé demande l'heure où
devait faire ça sur les haies par coup
ou sur les récifs
en fait on recherche les gros banc de
poisson
donc on en trouve près des épaves ça
arrive mais généralement en pêche à la
dynamite sur les récifs combien vous
pouvez gagner en une journée c'est 1000
dollars au minimum
mais si on attrape des centaines de
poissons c'est beaucoup plus que cela
donc la récompense est tellement grande
que ça fait oublier le danger le risque
de perdre sa vie perdre un bras humain
tous les risques sont oubliés ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ce n'est pas un
travail pénible ça peut prendre deux à
trois heures et sur la trappe le poisson
très vite c'est réglé en une heure
enfin la police même si j'étais policier
et que je vois mon frère utiliser la
dynamite
je vais le laisser tranquille je ne vais
pas m'arrêter je ne veux pas le voir en
prison
c'est comme ça que ça se passe ici je
pense qu'à l'avenir tout cela va changer
parce que la jeune génération était due
qu ils comprennent nos coutumes les
communes ont reçu une éducation
ils peuvent la mettre en pratique donc
je pense que les choses ont changé je
l'espère sont bientôt
et le plus tôt sera le mieux
choquette en train de perdre ses épaves
c'est à dire le seul trésor que les
occidentaux ont bien voulu lui laisser
est la seule économie substantielle qui
tiennent encore debout préserver cet
étrange trésor n'exigera pas seulement
un exploit scientifique
il faudra trouver le moyen d'intéresser
l'ensemble des tchouktches à protéger
ces épaves qui pour l'instant sont
encore loin de leur quotidien
je cherche comment les gens pourraient
bénéficier davantage des épaves
comment ça pourrait aider tout le monde
lorsque sauver les ai passées et des
lettres
en fait je me suis aperçu qu'au delà des
épaves
ce sont les gens d'ici qui m'apporte
vraiment ici les récifs se meurt les
poissons sont devenus tellement petit
quand on va au marché on trouve plus que
des petits poissons plus de gros à cause
de la dynamite
je ne sais pas ce qui va se passer dans
l'avenir avec ses récifs qui
disparaissent les poissons dépendent des
récifs je ne sais pas mon temps est
bientôt venue dans quelques années je
serais parti les autres je ne sais pas
comment ils vont faire
[Musique]
et
- et
[Musique]
il